khloe kardashian is not here for a
commentary about her family
i'm not here to play games the 36 year
old reality star wished
kanye west a happy birthday on tuesday
posting this sweet snap to instagram
featuring kanye his estranged wife kim
kardashian and
coco's boyfriend tristan thompson she
captioned the post quote
happy birthday to my brother for life
have the best birthday yay
sending you love and endless blessings
kim who also shared some birthday love
for her ex amid their divorce
slid into the comments of her sister's
post with a single red balloon emoji
you just gotta roll with it well that's
when one commenter decided to reply to
kim writing quote
i'm sorry kim the whole brother for life
thing is
too petty for me your sister bond should
be much more strong than feeling the
need to say that
your divorce was so hard on you even the
picture is just
uncalled for there is so many other
pictures
google could have been her friend this
wasn't cute but i'm glad you're being
strong through it all
and chloe she didn't appreciate the
commenter's two cents
oh no no she responded writing quote
why are you even commenting on something
you know nothing about
you don't think me and my sisters talk
about one another's feelings
we are with one another every day this
is my family
not yours don't comment as if you are in
the know unless you are
actually in the know weirdo
but chloe wasn't the only member of the
kardashian family to wish kanye a happy
b
day kris jenner shared this snap to her
insta story
and late tuesday night kourtney
kardashian followed suit
posting these pics of her own i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
kim filed for divorce from the 44 year
old grammy winner after six years of
marriage in february
and a source previously told et that kim
wouldn't shy away from addressing her
highly publicized marital issues on the
20th and final season of keeping up with
the kardashians
i honestly can't do this anymore
why am i still in this like place where
i'm stuck for years like he goes and
moves to a different state
everywhere i have to be like together so
i can raise the kids you know he's an
amazing dad he's done an amazing job the
whole thing he still will be and during
part one of the series finale
that's exactly what happened he deserves
someone that can go support his every
move
and go follow him all over the place and
move to wyoming i can't do that
he should have a wife that supports his
every move and travels with him and does
everything and and i just yeah
i feel like a [ __ ] failure that it's
like a third marriage yeah i feel like a
loser but i can't even think about that
like i want to be happy
in a sneak peek at part two kim sits
down with her mom
and opens up about the end of her
marriage i didn't come this far just to
come this far
and not be happy a source recently told
et
that the situation between kim and kanye
is quote
still pretty emotional and not fully
resolved
so it's been hard to completely close
this chapter
but last month the source told et that
kim is quote in a great headspace and
moving on
in the months since filing for divorce
adding that kim
is really focused on her family and has
been spending the majority of her time
with the kids
in life what i've learned is you just
kind of have to go with it
kim is continuing to be a great mom and
focusing on work
her life is definitely on the upswing